you're watching the press preview our
first look at the front pages
as they arrive over the next a half an
hour so we'll be taking a look at what's
making the headlines with the editor of
the cumberland and westmoreland herald
emily atherton
and the editor of politico's london
playbook alex wickham but before we do
let's take you through the front pages
that we have and of course one story is
dominating the daily mail says the pm is
on the ropes
from the combination of an alleged
comment about bodies being piled high
funding for number 10 decorations and a
leak inquiry
the allegations of sleaze are tainting
the prime minister
according to the eye a slurry of
sleaze is the metro's take on the story
thanks in part
to the photo there the telegraph says
that boris johnson is
fighting to move on from the wrong
picture again in a farmyard
and the guardian leading with the
headline pressure on johnson
after claim of slur on covet dead
the mirror responds to the alleged
comment with its headline
not just bodies bodis we love them
uh the star in typical star fashion also
weighing in
as does the sun uh it's reporting the
boris johnson says the claims
against him are simply put lies
similar sentiment repeated in the
express
i mean while the times has more claims
about boris johnson's comments
the headline johnson said he would let
covet rip in a lockdown round
and questions remain for the former
prime minister david cameron
the ft leading on revelations that the
financier lex green sill was a number 10
advisor
but one with no contract or indeed set
job role as you can see we are joined
tonight by emily everton
and alex wickham guys lovely to see you
both um
and emily let's start with you shall we
uh
it is always fortuitous when interesting
political stories happen in elections
because you get to see
the protagonist dressing up in all
manner of uh silly outfits on the front
of the metro it's boris johnson and
wellies the headline
[ __ ] of sleaze
absolutely this is um the metro
i've got a picture of boris johnson
visiting a farm in wales
they've captured him in a cattle shed
headed its slurry of sleaze and
this piece is by dominick yateman and
it's
it basically delves into the tsunami of
sleaze allegations that are currently
engulfing
the pm um everything from the
chatty rat claims and counter claims
that are involving
dominic cummings the costs on flat
refurbishment
number 10 well number 11 downing street
and
of course the green cell david cameron
lobby
lobbying uh allegations that are being
made
um it's it lends itself very well the
photo to the um
to the subject at hand i suppose it's um
yeah it's um the sort of
uh
well i can only describe it as a tsunami
they've
they've put rather cheeky captured on
the photo there which i won't uh
i won't repeat yeah good because i've
just seen it so please don't do that i
mean um alex i mean i i have to admit i
i'm slightly surprised that
the papers are still choosing to lead on
on those alleged comments rather than
necessarily
developments that are taking place on or
around the flat we still of course don't
have it on the register of ministers
interests
and but if you take a look at the eye
the key question in all of this
is whether any of it is actually you
know hitting home with the voters
some polling suggesting that it might
but of course lots of people
have already voted by post
yeah this is i suppose the only question
that really matters the
at the moment we've got the prime
minister we've got some former special
advisors we've got some journalists in
westminster having a
big row about some wallpapers some
whatsapp messages and it's all a little
bit inside baseball the thing that
really matters
is what the voters think always and you
know
at the moment the sort of perceived
wisdom in westminster is that this
hasn't really cut through to the general
public we've got the
local elections in 10 days time i think
and you know the
the general view in westminster is that
whenever allegations of sleaze and this
sort of
mud is slung around the voters kind of
think oh well all politicians are awful
all politicians are up to their next in
it
it doesn't really make a difference one
way or the other well this
poll on the front page of the eye it's
an interesting poll from redfield and
wilson strategies which has found that
half of voters do now think that
that this is a tory government mind in
sleaze which is the first
real sign that we've really had had that
that actually
people do have a bit of a problem with
this they do are getting a bit concerned
about about the stories that they've
been reading and
in the papers over the last couple of
weeks whether it is the flat whether it
is the
um you know the chatty rat uh story
whether it is um
advisors working for people that they
shouldn't officials working for people
that they shouldn't on the side
all of these sort of things that have
just snowballed into into a bit of a
narrative
and certainly if you speak to the labour
party they really do think that there is
something going on here they really do
think that this is something that they
can pursue
not necessarily one that might deliver
them a huge victory
they're coming up at the upcoming local
elections this isn't necessarily
something that
changes the way people think uh
overnight and obviously the tories still
do have a pretty healthy lead in most
polls at the moment
but if they just keep a sort of a
nutritional sort of
war of of of deadly users as we were
talking about earlier of these of these
these allegations
eventually building it up over months
and months and years and years as we've
found with governments in the past that
could become a real serious problem for
boris johnson
down the line um emily take us to the
front page of the financial times in
this story
again whether or not it cuts through
outside sw1p is it
is a different matter but it is still
gobsmacking
lex screensell working in downing street
having a security pass
not apparently no contract and this
information reaches us from none other
than the uk's most senior civil servant
who can't even get to the bottom of the
story
that's right simon case giving evidence
today to a
committee of mps at westminster um i
think
perhaps people hoped more would come out
of this by way of information
but you know what's come out to come out
and he's um
he said he was alarmed at the way things
played out
uh with the appointment of lex green
sill as you say without a contract
no real job description um
you know the evidence that he's given
there to the public administration
committee
um you know he was working for um
well this committee's also heard today
that civil servants were working for
outside bodies this apparently is quite
common practice
while still employed in the public
sector double hatting
um as it's known where people you know
conflict of interest
is is certainly an issue there isn't it
um this
is now going to be the subject of
another inquiry
um it's all centering around the green
cell affair the lobbying
and the the fact that senior civil
servants were employed
at green cell during a period that they
were still
uh there was still on the government
payroll
um so as i say this sort of double
hatting is now to become the subject of
another inquiry
i think today's evidence from simon case
uh people in the know i think will have
been watching that with interest hoping
that
um that more would have come out he was
certainly questioned during that
uh about about the chatty rats uh
scenario and the uh the flat
refurbishment
costs where the money came from sure and
i just want to bring an ounce as well on
this
just because we're just running out of
time before we head to the break but
let's just just
pause for a second and consider that
which the head of the civil service did
not know he didn't know alex
how many people were double hatting he
had to ask them doesn't know couldn't
explain exactly how the downing street
flat was paid for
the leak inquiries are still ongoing but
doesn't look like there's any chance of
success
i mean he's not covering himself in
glory the head of the uk civil service
is he
i think you've hit the net on the head i
mean this story is is not going away and
if simon case thinks he's
you know if his summer case is patting
himself on the back tonight thinking
well i got away with that one
i didn't manage to give anything away i
think he's got another thing coming
people
i'm hearing tonight within government as
well as across westminster are pretty
unimpressed with this performance by
simon case he is asking the select
committee who
he has to tell the truth to by the way
and even more so as the highest
public official in in the land at the
highest civil servant in the land
he's asking them to believe the number
10 flat does he know any of the details
about the renovations no he doesn't know
any of it uh
the chatty rat the in quite the leak
inquiry that's been going on for
probably about four or five months now
does he know
where we're getting where we're getting
with that is you know any idea
how close that is to conclusion or or
where that's headed
no he can't say anything about it no
idea and again
with most extraordinarily on these on
these lex green sil
allegations this the the revelation that
that this uh this financier was working
for for david cameron with a security
pass
with no contract um in downing street
while also
while also working um as a financier no
answers on that no idea if simon case
said he had about how and why this
arrangement was was happening and i just
think that just
he's going to have to do a lot better
and this story is not going to go away
and alex
let's go inside the metro show in a
story which perhaps i think the west
have been slightly slow to catch up with
but everyone is there and they're in
numbers and reporting on it which is
great the situation in
india is a catastrophe by any measure
yeah and you know it puts it all into
perspective really doesn't it
westminster has been consumed with this
sort of
navel gazing stuff as important as it is
on on
on tory alleged sleeves but what we've
seen
really illustrated quite shockingly by
the metro here
is just the the extent of the crisis in
india
you know 350 000 cases in a single day
uh two and a half thousand deaths but
the reality is that in a country of a
billion people obviously
that the testing is is is not getting
everyone and the the numbers are
just clearly clearly not possible to to
even fathom
and the real numbers are going to be
much much higher than that is is just a
horrendous uh scale we've seen this week
uh you know britain
sent 600 ventilators that announced
yesterday to india to try and help and
and um oxygen uh concentrated machines
as well
which is obviously you know a really
good thing you know you you do
think that you do wonder if perhaps uh
you know politicians in westminster had
stopped focusing perhaps a little bit on
on some of this relatively unimportant
stuff that's been going on in
in parliament at the moment at the
moment and you know been thinking about
what is going on perhaps this could have
happened slightly sooner and the next
thing is is going to be vaccines as well
which is going to be
you know the huge the huge argument is
you know obviously britain's numbers
have come right down
in part due to the lockdown but also in
large part due to the vaccine
how on earth do you get you know
hundreds of millions of vaccines
over to india in a very short amount of
time to try and
try and save this country from from an
appalling outcome
i mean emily i suppose as the ft kind of
suggests i mean that
the only way that we are going to stop
uh
the catastrophe continuing i should say
is for the world to come together
donations of vaccines are going to be
all important but of course you know
there is a domestic political angle
to any country that chooses to export
vaccine surplus or vaccine stock
in favor of giving it to their own
citizens
yeah um the prime minister of india
narendra modi
is uh being criticized internationally i
think for um
allowing the vaccine manufacturers
manufacturers to to sort of set their
own prices
um i mean i was struck by the sort of
powerful images in both
um the metro and and ft of
um really the suffering that people are
going through
i mean the metro focuses on a
a woman laid out in the back of a car
receiving
oxygen outside a temple it
you know there's a sort of self-help
element to all this that's having to
come into play which
you know it beggars belief really that
people are having to to to
almost beg and plead to get the oxygen
that they need
um as alex says that the key thing here
is going to be vaccines isn't it
um and the argument's been made hasn't
it that we're
you know rolling down the age groups
here in the uk
to to age groups that are arguably less
at risk of
bad outcomes when in countries such as
india
the uh you know the vulnerable age
groups are not actually
getting access to vaccines and it's
something's got to be done about that
and the us is weighing in with more
medical equipment
but that's fighting fire we we really
need to
you know what really needs to happen is
that you've got to cut off those
infections at source haven't you with
them
rolling out some vaccines